[Music]
I'm so sorry you're speeding let me get
your license registration Insurance um
my license actually is um with my
security at home and there I don't have
it with me right now at this moment I'm
so sorry but it's like 10 minutes away
um you're were going 60 and it's like a
45 I'm so sorry I'm so so sorry please
forgive me can I get registration
Insurance excuse me registration
Insurance oh I don't
know all my information is at my house
okay do you have a valid license uh yes
sir it's um I just flew in from um
overseas so they have my security in the
house have my I've stopped you before
out here for speeding I stopped you
before out here for
speeding I gave you a break last
time
um all right can I get your full
name with
middle
dat do you don't have a registration in
the
car um do you have
insurance doesn't your security doesn't
your security usually follow you no my
security is at the house he's at the
house okay um are you able to have them
bring your stuff excuse me can you have
them bring your information can you
drive there no I mean I no I don't want
to do that or you can send you a picture
of the uh insurance can you hear me um
can you sec to send a picture of my
registration and my license please and
insurance and what and insurance and
insurance to to this go to my phone so I
can show to your okay just wait here for
me
okay
[Music]
damn
Sho was clear d
[Music]
Spears here we
go
[Music]
sh
I don't know what kind of
was oh my God
[Music]
see
31 one North
[Music]
right trans
trans
[Music]
what here's a picture of my
passport um but this is the girl she she
has on my information okay um can I get
your current address okay here she is uh
talk to him right now he's right here
little do you hide seat her current
address
[Music]
okay like her license and stuff and the
insurance okay yeah she needs to carry
it all needs to be in the
vehicle um you know the name of the
insurance company at
least okay did you and you don't have
her license
either
okay yeah it'll have to be afterwards
she can just you guys can just show it
to the court for as proof okay
right to the to the court
hold yeah go ahead um Miss spear can I
get your
address
um is that considered uh Thousand Oaks
and then what's the ZIP
code what was it I one through supp okay
okay cool all right just wait
[Music]
here
for
[Music]
right
for all right ma'am um so I'm going to
write you a fix a ticket for the license
and then not having proof of insurance
um I'm guessing you do have insurance
but you need to have it in the vehicle
are accessible so if you're get in a car
crash you can exchange it um versus
having to try to juggle it back and
forth um just sign in the red box by
signing or not admitting anything I'm
going to give you a warning for speeding
by the way um just sign in the red box
by signing or not admitting anything
you're just promising you're to take
care with the court they should send you
a notice to your address um in general
you can just show proof to any law
enforcement you have your license and
then you have the insurance they can
sign off on the ticket or and then you
talk to the court with how to take care
of it okay thank you or have your
assistant take care of it um please slow
down out here this is the second time
okay there's your copy you're free to
[Music]
go